OPERA AND THE DRAMA RIGHT NOW IS
ON FIRE.
WE CONTINUE TO DIVE INTO THE NBA
PLAYOFFS LIVE IN "THE GROUP
CHAT" PRESENTED BY FanDUEL.
THANK YOU FOR TAPPING IN.
MY NAME IS CABBIE RICHARDS.
SHE STILL PRESSED THE PROCESS
WHILE COMBING THROUGH THE DATA.
THATSRI
AVE HOODIES, AS USUAL,
EVERYBODY.
WE ALSO HAVE GOT JERSEYS.
HMM, I'M FEELING GENEROUS.
I'M FEELING GENEROUS.
WHY NOT?
THIS RIGHT HERE, THIS IS THE
HANDY DANDY iPAD.
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY
RIGHT NOW.
WHY NOT?
GIVEAWAY A JERYIGHT N AND I SEE
HERE WE GO.
I GOT TOWEL PACKA 68 SAYS K.D.
WILL PUT UP 42 TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, TOWEL PACKA.
THOSE ARE GOOD VIBES FOR
EVERYBODY THAT IS BENDING THE
OVER.
SO I'M GOING TO SEE -- ACTUALLY,
I'M NOT SENDING A TEE SHIRT.
I'M NOT SENDING A HOODIE.
YOU JUST WON A JERSEY.
YOU JUST WON $125 TO PICK OUT
ANY JERSEY THAT YOU WANT.
CABBIE, GET THE SHOW ON THE
ROAD.
>> WELL DONE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE GAME
TONIGHT.
IN THEIR TWO HOME GAMES IN THE
SERIES BROOKLYN HIT 36
THREE-POINTERS.
IN MILWAUKEE'S LAST HOME GAME,
THE BUCS SPLASHED 16
THREE-POINTERS.
SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THE
THREE-BY-TWO IS BACK, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN!
>> YEAH!
>> WILL THERE BE TWO
THREE-POINTERS MADE IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
LAST NIGHT THE THREE-BY-TWO HIT
IN THE CLIPPERS VERSUS JAZZ
SERIES.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
WE WANT TO THANK KAWHI LEONARD
AND MARCUS MORRIS.
MUCH APPRECIATED, GENTS.
THERE'S THE TERMINATOR, KAWHI
HIT THREE FROM DOWNTOWN.
MARCUS MORRIS HAD HIS BEST GAME
IN A CLIPPERS' UNIFORM, THROWING
FIVE FOR SIX FROM THREE-POINT
RANGE.
LET'S LOOK AT TONIGHT'S GAME,
SHALL WE?
GREG, IT LOOKS LIKE HARDEN IS IN
FOR GAME FIVE.
HE'S AVAILABLE, SO THERE'S A
CHANCE HE MIGHT HIT A COUPLE OF
STEPBACKS, BUT WHAT DOES THE
AUDIENCE THINK ABOUT TONIGHT'S
GAME?
THERE ARE THE ODDS FOR THE
THREE-BY-TWO, MINUS 110.
WHAT DO WE GOT?
HOW DO THEY FEEL ABOUT IT?
>> LET ME ASK THEM, CABBIE.
HEY, AUDIENCE, JUST REPLY "YES,"
HOW ABOUT THAT?
NO, NO, SERIOUSLY.
LET ME ASK.
WILL THE THREE-BY-TWO HIT --
>> ARE WE GOING TO MAKE IT
HARDER THAN THAT?
>> WILL THE THREE-BY-TWO HIT
TONIGHT?
YOU GUYS FILL THOSE COMMENTS UP
WITH PREFERABLY "YESES" AND GET
CREATIVE.
ERIN, I HAVE TO TALK TO YOU, I
HAVE TO GET YOUR TAKE, GET YOUR
RUN DOWN.
DO YOU THINK THE THREE-BY-TWO IS
HITTING TONIGHT?
I MEAN FanDUEL HAS IT AT MINUS
110.
LIKE IS THAT A LOCK?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
I MEAN HOW DO YOU NOT PUT THE
THREE-BY-TWO CASHING AFTER THOSE
STATS CABBIE MENTIONED AS WELL
AND THAT'S 36 THREE-POINTERS IN
FIRST TWO HOME GAMES OF THE
SHOOTERS.
SHOOTERS ON BOTH TEAMS.
I'M TAKING THIS AND I'M EXCITED
THAT IT IS BACK.
>> THE CROWD IS GOING TO BE
JUICED TONIGHT.
YOU KNOW, BLAKE GRIFFIN OR KEVIN
DURANT MIGHT GET STARTED FOR THE
NETS.
DON'T BE SURPRISED IF BROOKE
LOPEZ OR GIANNIS FOR MILWAUKEE
SPLASHES A THREE IN THE
THREE-BY-TWO HITS BEFORE THE
NINE MINUTE MARK.
WE NEED THESE WINS.
G MONEY, ARE WE AUTO LOCKING THE
THREE-BY-TWO?
>> CABBIE, IS THE SKY BLUE?
IS MONEY GLEAN?
>> YES.
ALSO YES.
>> IT IS NOT EVEN A QUESTION.
IT IS NOT EVEN A QUESTION
WHETHER WE ARE ROCKING THIS
THREE, ROCKING WITH THIS
THREE-BY-TWO.
YES, WE ARE HAMMERING THE
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
HEY, I SEE A LOT OF CREATIVE
GIFTS IN HERE, CABBIE.
I TOLD THEM TO BE CREATIVE AND
THEY ARE.
I HAVE NAME, NAMELESS.
NAMELESS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, NAMELESS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HE HAS A FUNNY GPH HERE, SHOUT
OUT TO YOU, NAMELESS.
HERE IT IS.
THERE IT IS.
>> AMAZING.
>> THERE IT IS.
I ALSO GOT RICHIE.
I GOT RICHIE 21.
RICHIE 21 WITH THE SPORT, YES.
HEY, CABBIE, THE COMMENTS ARE
ACTUALLY POPPING RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU ARE NOT IN THE COMMENTS,
YOU ARE LOSING BECAUSE THIS IS
HOW YOU GET HOODIES, THIS IS HOW
YOU GET JERSEYS.
AND THIS IS HOW YOU JUST, YOU
KNOW, GET TAPPED IN ON THE SHOW.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT IS
ROCKING WITH US IN THE COMMENTS.
I GAVE AWAY TWO.
I THINK WE CAN -- I THINK WE CAN
MOVE ON.
I THINK WE CAN MOVE ON.
>> OKAY.
HEY, SALUTE TO WHOEVER THAT WAS
WITH THE THOR RAGNA ROCK GPH.
THAT WAS DOPE.
KEY INJURIES MADE THIS SERIES SO
MUCH HARDER TO CAP FOR BOOK
MAKERS AND FANS.
JAMES HARDEN HAS BEEN UPGRADED
TO QUESTIONABLE AND HE IS GOING
TO PARTICIPATE IN WARM-UPS.
KYRIE IRVING IS OUT WITH A BADLY
TWISTED ANKLE.
HE WAS SEEN LEAVING MILWAUKEE
WITH AN AIR CAST ON HIS FOOT.
SO THE QUESTION IS CAN THE SLIM
REAPER, KEVIN DURANT, CARRY HIS
BROOKLYN NETS TO VICTORY IN GAME
FIVE?
HOW MANY POINTS DO YOU THINK
K.D. WILL SCORE TONIGHT AGAINST
THE MILWAUKEE BUCS?
GREG, WHAT DO THE PEOPLE HAVE TO
DO TO TAKE HOME A JERSEY, SIR,
AS WE LOOK AT THE POSTS ON
SOCIAL FROM EARLIER TODAY?
>> IN ORDER FOR YOU GUYS TO TAKE
HOME A JERSEY, GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME HOW MANY
POINTS K.D. IS PUTTING UP
TONIGHT.
AT THE END OF THE GAME, WE'LL DM
YOU, ONE PERSON WHO GUESSED THE
CLOSEST AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
JERSEY.
ERIN, K.D. IS SITTING AT 33 1/2
FOR TONIGHT.
DO YOU LIKE THAT NUMBER?
DO YOU LIKE THAT NUMBER, ARE YOU
GOING OVER OR UNDER?
>> I'M ACTUALLY GOING UNDER ON
THIS.
K.D. IS ONLY AVERAGING 30 POINT
PER GAME IN THE SERIES.
HE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO HIT OVER
33 1/2 POINTS IN ANY OF THE
GAMES DURING THE SERIES.
IN GAME FOUR AGAINST THE BUCS HE
SCORED 28 POINTS ON 9 OF 25
SHOOTING FROM THE FLOOR, SO I
EXPECT TO SO POSITIVE REGRESSION
IN K.D. IN TERMS OF HIS SHOOTING
PERFORMANCE, BUT I'M STILL
TAKING UNDER 33 1/2 WITH THE
POTENTIAL THAT HE COULD BE
DOUBLE-TEAMED IN THIS GAME.
ALSO, AN IMPORTANT NOTE, THE
LINE FOR K.D.'S PLAYER PROP
CONTINUES TO MOVE DOWN.
IT OPENED AT 35 1/2.
>> OKAY.
SO AS G MONEY IS ABOUT TO GIVE
AWAY A JERSEY, ERIN, ARE YOU ONE
OF THOSE SPORTS FANS, WE KNOW
YOU ARE IN PHILADELPHIA --
>> YES.
>> -- THAT WHEN THE GAME IS ON,
LIKE YOU THROW ON ONE OF YOUR
SEVERAL PHILADELPHIA SIXERS'
JERSEYS AND WHICH ONE DID YOU
WEAR LAST NIGHT WHEN EMBIID AND
BEN SIMMONS TOOK THE "L" AGAINST
ATLANTA?
>> YES.
SEE, SO I'M NOT CRAZY
SUPERSTITIOUS WHERE I HAVE TO
WEAR CERTAIN SIXERS OUTFIT
BASICALLY IN TERMS OF WANTING
THEM TO WIN, BUT LAST NIGHT I
WAS LAYING IN BED AND I WAS JUST
GETTING MORE HEATED AND
DISAPPOINTED.
I WAS HAPPY I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
SIXERS GEAR ON.
I'M ONE OF THOSE FANS.
I DEFINITELY GET DECKED OUT IN
SOMETHING PHILADELPHIA SPORTS
EVERY GAME.
>> MAYBE YOU WERE THE JINX
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T WEAR THE
PHILADELPHIA JERSEY.
>> BECAUSE I DIDN'T WEAR IT THIS
TIME, COULD BE.
>> MIKE BUDENHOLZER IS A GREAT
COACH.
HE HAS WON COACH OF THE YEAR
BEFORE.
I MEAN HE DOES GET KNOCKED
BECAUSE IN THE PAST HE HASN'T
BEEN MAKING THAT MANY IN-GAME
ADJUSTMENT GOES.
I THINK TONIGHT THE K.D.
DOUBLE-TEAM IS COMING.
YOU CAN'T STOP KEVIN DURANT, YOU
CAN ONLY HOPE TO CONTAIN HIM.
SEND IN BOBBY PORTIS, SEND IN ON
THE WEAK SIDE TO HELP GUARD
KEVIN DURANT.
I'M GOING TO SAY HE IS GOING
UNDER 33 1/2 POINTS, AND IF
JAMES HARDEN PLAYS, 15 TO 20
MINUTES, THEN MAYBE HARDEN WILL
DO SOME OF THE SCORING THAT K.D.
WOULD HAVE DONE WITHOUT THE
BEARD NEXT TO HIM ON THE
LINE-UP.
SO UNDER 33 1/2 FOR ME.
G MONEY, DO YOU THINK THAT K.D.
WILL BE IRRITATED ENOUGH OR
THROWN OFF HIS GAME ENOUGH TO
SCORE UNDER THE 33 1/2 THAT BOTH
ERIN AND I THINK HE WILL NOT HIT
TONIGHT?
>> CABBIE, I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
GO ON THE OTHER SIDE OF YOU TWO.
I ACTUALLY THINK HE'S GOING TO
BE IRRITATED AND THAT'S GOING TO
ENHANCE HIS PLAY.
I SAW K.D. ACTUALLY TALKING TO
THE MEDIA EARLIER AND SAYING IN
THIS GAME HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
DO EVERYTHING.
IF HE'S GOING IN THERE WITH THAT
TYPE OF MINDSET, K.D. MIGHT GO
FOR 50 TONIGHT.
I MEAN NOBODY CAN GUARD HIM.
LIKE NO ONE IN THE -- HONESTLY,
I REALLY THINK NO ONE ONE-ON-ONE
CAN GUARD KEVIN DURANT IN THE
NBA.
I MEAN YOU NAMED DREW HOLIDAY,
PAT CONNINGTON, BOBBY PORTIS.
NO, NO, CABBIE.
NO, NO, NO.
>> NOT THE PRIMARY DEFENDERS,
HELP DEFENDERS.
>> NO, CABBIE.
NO.
I MEAN EVEN IF THEY COME, BRING
THE HELP, I SEE K.D. BEING A
PLAYMAKER.
WE KNOW HE CAN DO THIS.
WE SAW THIS IN GOLDEN STATE.
I MEAN WE'VE SEEN IT AT TIMES
WITH THIS BROOKLYN TEAM.
K.D. IS GOING TO BE OKAY.
HE'S GOING TO BE OKAY.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE A REALLY GOOD
GAME, BUT I THINK HE'S GOING TO
SCORE THE BASKETBALL.
I DO THINK HE'S GOING TO SCORE
THE BASKETBALL.
LET ME GET INTO THIS COMMENTS
THOUGH, CABBIE.
LET ME GET INTO THESE COMMENTS
BECAUSE I GOT KEEN WITH SPORTS,
HE'S AGREEING WITH HIM.
KING OF SPORTS SAYS 40 PIECE,
MAKE MY WORD, K.D. WILL BALL
TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, KINGDOM SPORTS
21.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT MONEY MAN 13 SAYS, OVER,
K.D. IS TAKING OVER AND IT IS IN
BROOKLYN, MEANING K.D. IS GOING
TO SHOW UP IN BROOKLYN TONIGHT,
CABBIE.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO MY GUY, MONEY
MAN, BECAUSE I'M A MAN OF MY
MONEY TOO.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT KING SMOOTH.
KING SMOOTH SAYS, NAH, AND
HARDEN WILL LEAD THE GAME INTO
THE FIRST QUARTER, BUCS IN SIX.
SO HE SAYS K.D. IS GOING UNDER.
HE IS ROCKING WITH YOU, ERIN,
AND YOU, CABBIE.
MOVES 23, UNDER SCORE SIX.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
EVERYBODY, WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS
TO DO IS GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
GIVE ME A NUMBER.
GIVE ME A NUMBER THAT YOU THINK
KEVIN DURANT IS GOING TO END THE
GAME WITH.
WHOEVER GETS THE CLOSEST,
WHOEVER GETS THE CLOSEST, I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU A JERSEY.
I AM GOING TO GIVE YOU A JERSEY.
WE ARE ALSO GOING TO GIVE AWAY
TWO MORE JERSEYS IN THIS SHOW.
WE ARE GIVING AWAY TWO MORE,
CABBIE.
ERIN.
THE GIFTS ARE STILL FLOWING.
>> ARE WE DOING, LIKE, WHEEL OF
FORTUNE RULES, LIKE CLOSEST
WITHOUT GOING OVER?
>> CABBIE, THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
HOPEFULLY, I MEAN, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENT, SOMEBODY WILL GET IT
RIGHT ON THE DOT.
>> YEAH, OKAY.
>> BUT, YEAH, HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY
GETS IT RIGHT ON THE DOT, BUT
WE'LL SEE, MAN.
WE'LL SEE.
WE MIGHT HAVE TO GO, YOU KNOW,
I'LL HAVE TO TALK TO THE POWERS
THAT MAY BE AND SEE, FIGURE IT
OUT.
>> THE JERSEY GATE KEEPERS,
RIGHT.
I LIKE THIS COMMENT FROM ZAPPO
45 WHO WROTE, 22 POINTS.
AT ONE POINT IN THE GAME ONE OF
HIS SNEAKERS WILL FLY OFF HIS
FOOT.
I LOVE IT.
LISTEN, WITH --
>> ZAPPO 45 IS GETTING A HOODIE
FOR THAT.
>> WHILE INJURY TALK HAS
DOMINATED THE BETTING SPHERE AND
SPORTS TALK RADIO, THE GREEK
GOOD, GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO, IS
AVERAGING 30 POINTS, 12 REBOUNDS
AND THREE ASSISTS IN THE SERIES.
NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT THE
GREEK GOD AND HE IS A GOD.
ONE OF THE MOST FUN PROPS,
PLAYER PROPS TO BET ON IS
POINTS, PLUS REBOUNDS, PLUS
ASSISTS.
G-MONEY, WHICH FAN OF BROOKLYN
OR MILWAUKEE OR MAYBE EVEN
PHILLY, NEEDS A JERSEY TO ENJOY
THE REST OF THE SERIES AND
POTENTIALLY AN APPEARANCE IN THE
NBA?
>> LET ME FIND OUT.
LET ME TALK TO THEM.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, GUYS, AND
TELL ME HOW MANY POINTS,
REBOUNDS AND ASSISTS GIANNIS IS
PUTTING UP TONIGHT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY A HOODIE
AND A JERSEY FOR THIS ONE.
ERIN, ARE YOU ON THE OVER OR
UNDER HERE?
>> WELL, I'M ON THE UNDER HERE,
LIKE CABBIE MENTIONED.
IN THE SERIES GREEK FREAK
AVERAGING 30 POINTS, 12 BOARDS,
THREE ASSISTS.
ALSO 51 1/2 SEEMS WAY TOO HIGH
FOR ME, ESPECIALLY GIVEN HE HAS
NOT HIT THAT NUMBER IN ANY OF
THE GAMES PLAYED IN THE SERIES.
IT WILL BE A HUGE GAME FOR
GIANNIS IN THE BARCLAY'S CENTER.
I HATE TAKING UNDERS AS WELL,
BUT I HAVE TO TAKE UNDER ON THIS
PROP.
>> 51 1/2 IS A HIGH NUMBER FOR
GIANNIS, BUT IT IS ATTAINABLE
FOR HIM.
HE IS AN ELITE SCORER, ELITE
REBOUNDER, SOLID PASSER.
STRATEGICALLY I THINK THE REASON
HE DOESN'T GET TO 51 1/2 POINTS,
REBOUNDS AND ASSISTS THE NIGHT
IS FREE THROWS.
GIANNIS IS DREADFUL IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
IF I'M STEVE NASH, THEN I'M
HACKING THE GUY IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER AND PUTTING HIM ON THE
CHARITY STRIPE BECAUSE HE IS
SHOOTING UNDER 40% FROM FREE
THROWS.
THAT'S WHY I THINK HE IS GOING
UNDER THE 51 1/2.
ERIN, WHEN YOU WATCH BEN
SIMMONDS IN PHILADELPHIA GET TO
THE FREE-THROW LINE, ARE YOU --
>> I CRINGE.
>> YOU CRINGE?
I CRINGE SO HARD, AND THEY KEPT
DOING IT ON PURPOSE WHICH IS
WORSE, AND EVERY TIME HE WOULD
GO TO THE LINE IT WAS TERRIBLE
TO WATCH.
THEY SHOULD HAVE LIVE LINES WHEN
HE GOES TO THE LINE, OVER/UNDER,
TOO.
>> THAT'S NOT A BAD IDEA.
GREG AND I WATCHED HIM LAST
NIGHT, AND I'M NOT SURE THAT HE
HIT ONE FREE THROW AGAINST THE
HAWKS IN GAME FOUR.
G-MONEY, GIANNIS, GIANNIS IS IN
BROOKLYN TONIGHT.
THERE'S LIKELY GOING TO BE A
STAR-STUDDED AUDIENCE.
WE KNOW THAT THE QUEEN BEY HAS
ATTENDED HOME, HAS ATTENDED.
TRAVIS SCOTT HAS BEEN THERE FOR
SOME OF THE BROOKLYN NETS'
GAMES.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE GREEK GOD
IS GOING TO GO OFF TONIGHT?
>> OH, CABBIE.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING QUESTION.
THAT IS AN INTERESTING QUESTION
BECAUSE THE LIGHTS ARE GOING TO
BE BRIGHT IN BROOKLYN.
LIKE YOU SAID, I MEAN WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE CELEBRITIES IN THE
STANDS.
IT IS GOING TO BE A BIG GAME.
ALL EYES ARE GOING TO BE ON THIS
GAME TONIGHT.
IT IS 2-2.
YOU KNOW, THE WINNER IS GOING TO
TAKE A LEAD IN THIS SERIES.
I DO SEE GIANNIS -- I DO SEE HIM
HAVING A GOOD GAME TONIGHT.
I DO SEE HIM HAVING A GOOD GAME
TONIGHT.
I DO SEE HIM POSSIBLY PUTTING ON
A SHOW.
BUT IS HE GOING TO PUT ON AN
ABSOLUTE SHOW?
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S GOING TO
PUT ON THIS SHOW TO GO OVER
51 1/2 ON THIS COMBINED POINTS,
REBOUNDS AND ASSISTS.
THAT'S A LOT OF POINTS.
I MEAN THAT'S A LOT.
THAT IS A LOT, IT IS A LOT OF
POINTS, A LOT OF REBOUNDS AND A
LOT OF ASSISTS.
SO I'M GOING TO GO UNDER HERE.
I'M GOING TO GO UNDER.
CABBIE, YOU MADE A GREAT POINT
ABOUT THE FREE THROWS.
GIANNIS, I MEAN HE GOES TO THE
FREE-THROW LINE AND HE MISSES
MORE THAN HE MAKES.
SO I MEAN THAT COULD BE A KEY
POINT IN NOT WINNING THIS BET,
OR BETTING -- IF I WAS TO BET
THE OVER AND LOSING.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH THE UNDER
HERE.
STICKING WITH THE UNDER.
THAT'S ENOUGH.
>> WAIT.
HOLD ON.
WAIT.
ERIN, DO YOU WANT TO CHANGE
YOURS?
I DON'T KNOW IF THE THREE OF US
HAVE EVER BEEN IN AGREEMENT ON
ONE OF THESE PLAYER PROPS.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> CHANGE OVER ON HIM.
THE LAST TIME THEY WERE PLAYING
IN BARCLAY'S CENTER THEY GOT
BLOWN OUT.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
THEY WERE DOWN BY 49 POINTS AT
ONE POINT IN GAME TWO.
>> THAT WAS BAD.
>> RIGHT.
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS,
WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT.
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO LET IT RIDE, G-MONEY.
>> YEAH, THIS IS RARE.
THIS IS RARE.
YOU KNOW, LET'S KEEP THE VIBES.
MAYBE THE VIBES -- MAYBE WE GOT
SOME GOOD VIBES RIGHT HERE,
ROLLING ON THE SAME SIDE FOR
ONCE.
>> YES.
>> SO LET'S LET IT RIDE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, CABBIE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I NEED TO GIVE AWAY -- I NEED TO
GIVE AWAY A HOODIE AND I NEED TO
GIVE AWAY A JERSEY.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, CABBIE,
ERIN, AND I SEE BOSTON VERSUS
EVERYONE.
THEY SAY 42 POINTS, 14 BOARDS,
SIX ASSISTS.
HEARD IT HERE FIRST.
I'M TAKING THE OVER WITH THE
GREEK GOD.
HEY, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, BOSTON.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
GOT HOW THE GREEK GOD IS
LOOKING, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
GO WHITE SOX IS IN THE COMMENTS,
CABBIE.
ERIN.
HE IS GOING WITH THE UNDER AND
HE HAS GIANNIS HITTING THE WHOA.
YOU GUYS SEE RIGHT THERE, THE
WHOA.
>> EVEN THOUGH YOU DO IT.
>> SHOW US HOW TO DO IT, ERIN.
>> NO, I'M NOT GOING TO
EMBARRASS MYSELF HERE.
>> NO, BUT --
>> THAT WOULD GO VIRAL.
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY -- I'M
GOING TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY HERE
RIGHT NOW.
GIVEAWAY A JERSEY.
HERE WE GO.
IN THE COMMENTS, IN THE
COMMENTS.
I SEE RICHIE 21.
RICHIE 21 GOT 32, 14 AND 6.
32, 14 AND 6.
THAT'S 52.
THAT MEANS HE'S GOING WITH THE
OVER.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, RICHIE.
EVEN THOUGH YOU ARE FADING ME,
GUESS WHAT?
I'M BEING GENEROUS.
YOU'RE GOING TO WALK AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
>> VERY DOPE.
OKAY.
WE ARE THREE HOURS, WE ARE UNDER
THREE HOURS BEFORE TIP-OFF, SO
WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER, WHO IS
GOING TO WIN THIS SERIES,
MILWAUKEE OR BOSTON.
LET'S SEE THE TWITTER POLL.
THERE'S PLUS MONEY THERE WITH
THE BROOKLYN NETS AT PLUS 154.
AMERICA IS VOTING.
51% WITH BROOKLYN.
I GUESS THEY LIKE THAT PLUS
MONEY.
GREG, BROOKLYN IS A HOME DOG
TONIGHT AND AN UNDERDOG IN THIS
SERIES AS WE SEE PLUS 154.
HOW ARE YOU AND YOUR
WINNERS-ONLY ARMY FEELING ABOUT
THE NETS IN GAME FIVE AND THIS
SERIES?
>> CABBIE, I'M LOVING THE PLUS
MONEY.
ACTUALLY, IF YOU -- HEY, IF YOU
GUYS HAD A FUTURE TICKET ON THE
NETS, THEN YOU MIGHT AS WELL
SPRINKLE SOME MORE BECAUSE I'M
LOVING THIS.
NETS, PLUS MONEY RIGHT NOW.
I'M LOVING IT.
BUT, YOU GUYS, GET IN THE
COMMENTS.
TELL ME WHO YOU THINK IS WINNING
THIS SERIES.
I'M GIVING AWAY A JERSEY TO THE
HOTTEST TAKE.
WHY NOT?
ERIN, TALK TO ME.
I KNOW YOU SEE THAT PLUS MONEY,
PLUS 120 IS LOOKING MIGHTY
TEMPTING.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS WINNING THIS
SERIES, MILWAUKEE OR BROOKLYN?
>> I HAVE TO TAKE BROOKLYN WITH
THE PLUS MONEY.
I KNOW IT HASN'T BEEN ANNOUNCED
JUST YET, THE SEVERITY OF KYRIE
IRVING'S ANKLE INJURY, BUT THE
NETS ARE ACCUSTOMED TO PLAYING
WITHOUT THAT TRIO ON THE FLOOR.
HARDEN AND IRVING ONLY PLAYED
EIGHT GAMES TOGETHER ON THE
SEASON.
ANOTHER ALARMING STAT, THE NETS
WON ONLY FOUR OF THE FIVE GAMES
DURANT PLAYING EVEN WITHOUT
HARDEN OR KYRIE ON THE FLOOR.
THE LAST GAME WITH NOT BEING
PREPARED TO LOSE KYRIE KIND OF
THREW HIM OFF A TAD, SO I THINK
NOW WE KNOW JAMES HARDEN COULD
POTENTIALLY BE BACK IN, HE MIGHT
HAVE A DIFFERENT MINDSET.
I THINK THE NETS WIN THE SERIES
BUT I THINK THEY DO IT IN GAME
SEVEN IN THE BARCLAY CENTER.
>> OH, HOT TAKE.
I LOVE IT.
EVERY REMAINING TEAM IN THE
PLAYOFFS HAS A SIGNIFICANT
INJURY TO THEIR STARTING LINE-UP
EXCEPT FOR PHOENIX.
WE SAW THAT LeBRON COULDN'T GET
OUT OF THE FIRST ROUND WITHOUT
ANTHONY DAVIS.
PHILADELPHIA IS WITHOUT DANNY
GREEN.
ATLANTA WITHOUT DeANDRE TURNER.
MIKE CONNELLY IS SUFFERING FROM
A HAMSTRING INJURY JUST LIKE
JAMES HARDEN.
ADD KYRIE BADLY TWISTING HIS
ANKLE, AND I THINK IN THIS
SPECIFIC CASE WITH BROOKLYN AND
MILWAUKEE, THE INJURIES ARE TOO
SIGNIFICANT TO OVERCOME.
THERE'S NO PRESSURE ON KEVIN
DURANT WITHOUT HIS SUPERSTAR
TEAMMATES BUT THERE'S A TON OF
UPSIDE.
HOWEVER, I THINK THE HEALTHY --
I'M GOING WITH THE HEALTHIER
TEAM IN THIS CASE.
I'M SIDING WITH THE BUCS.
GIVE ME THE MILWAUKEE BUCS TO
WIN IN SIX OR SEVEN.
OBVIOUSLY THEY CAN ONLY WIN IN
SIX OR SEVEN.
BUT GIVE ME THE MILWAUKEE BUCS
TO ADVANCE TO THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE FINALS AND
POTENTIALLY PLAY ERIN'S 76ers.
G-MONEY, HAVE YOU CHANGED YOUR
MIND ABOUT THE BROOKLYN NETS
CONSIDERING YOU HOLD A FUTURES
TICKET ON THAT SQUAD WITHOUT
THEIR SUPERSTARS IN THE
LINE-UPS, OR NOT FULLY HEALTHY
SUPERSTARS IN THE LINE-UPS?
>> CABBIE, I'VE NOT CHANGED MY
MIND.
I'VE NOT CHANGED MY MIND AT ALL.
I HAVEN'T CHANGED MY MIND AT
ALL, SIR.
I SEE THEM WINNING THIS SERIES,
AND THIS IS -- LIKE I KEEP ON
SAYING IT, BUT THIS PLUS MONEY
ON THE BROOKLYN NETS TO WIN THE
SERIES, YOU GUYS, GO GET ON THIS
NOW BECAUSE I LIKE IT.
I LIKE IT A LOT.
I DO SEE THEM WINNING THIS
SERIES.
THEY'RE GETTING JAMES HARDEN
BACK TODAY, HOPEFULLY.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, HOPEFULLY
EVERYTHING GOES WELL.
YOU KNOW HE'S A BIG ASSET FOR
THIS TEAM.
HIM WITH K.D., CABBIE, I
PERSONALLY THINK HIM AND K.D.
CAN GET IT DONE.
WHAT I MEAN GET IT DONE, WIN THE
WHOLE THING BY THEMSELVES.
SO IF THEY GET JAMES BACK AND
THEN THEY GET KYRIE BACK AND
THEN THE THREE, THE BIG THREE?
COME ON, CABBIE.
COME ON, MAN.
COME ON.
SO I LIKE THIS A LOT.
I LIKE THIS A LOT.
LET ME GIVEAWAY SOME HOODIES
THOUGH.
LET ME GIVEAWAY SOME HOODIES,
AND ALSO GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
HERE WE GO.
I NEED -- I GOT K.D. THE GREAT
SAYS, I NEED TO REP THE NETS'
JERSEY AFTER THEY WIN THE
SERIES.
SO HE'S LOCKING IN.
THEN HE ALSO SAYS, NETS DON'T
NEED KYRIE TO BEAT THE BUCS.
NETS IN SEVEN.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> STOP IT.
STOP IT.
>> CABBIE.
CABBIE, WHAT DID HE SAY WRONG?
WHAT DID HE SAY WRONG?
>> I GUESS WE'LL SEE.
I GUESS WE'LL SEE BECAUSE KYRIE
WILL PROBABLY -- I DON'T KNOW
HOW QUICKLY HE RECOVERS.
MAYBE HE IS AN X-MAN OR SOME
KIND OF SUPERHERO, BUT WHEN HE
ROLLED HIS ANKLE ON GIANNIS'S
FOOT, BRO, LIKE ALL OF HIS BODY
WEIGHT CAME ON HIS ANKLE.
COME ON.
NETS WINNING WITHOUT KYRIE
AGAINST THE BUCS?
STOP.
>> WE'LL SEE, CABBIE.
I GUESS -- I DO, I JUST SAID IT.
I JUST SAID IT.
IF JAMES HARDEN COMES BACK, I
CAN SEE JAMES AND K.D. WINNING
IT ALL.
I CAN SEE IT.
I CAN DEFINITELY SEE IT.
CABBIE, LET ME GIVEAWAY SOME
MORE.
>> ERIN'S 76ers, THEY'VE GOT
SIMMONDS AND THYBULLE WHO WILL
PUT THE CLAMPS.
THEY WILL APPLY SOME PRESSURE.
NOT FULL CLAMPS, BUT SOME
PRESSURE ON HARDEN AND K.D.
THOSE TWO ARE ELITE, AND --
SORRY, PLEASE CONTINUE.
PLEASE CONTINUE.
>> WHAT?
>> I FEEL LIKE IT IS ALMOST LIKE
THE WHOLE SITUATION WITH A.D.
WHEN WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO, JUST WHEN
HE WAS GOING TO COME IN AND SEE
HOW HE PLAYS.
NOW WE ARE KIND OF IN THE SAME
SITUATION WITH HARDEN, SO WE'RE
BANKING ON HIM TO BE OKAY BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF HE CAN REALLY DO
THAT JUST YET.
I FEEL LIKE WE'RE -- I MEAN THE
NETS AT PLUS MONEY, I FEEL LIKE
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THAT OVER THE
MILWAUKEE BUCS.
>> HOLD ON.
THAT'S A GREAT POINT, ERIN,
BECAUSE LIKE WE SAW WITH ANTHONY
DAVIS, DID HE COME BACK TOO
FAST?
HE WAS NOT 100%, AND THEN
ULTIMATELY, BOOM, HE IS OUT
AGAIN.
JAMES HARDEN -- LIKE HE WAS OUT
FOR A MONTH WITH THE HAMSTRING
INJURY.
>> YES.
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN HE IS GOING
TO BE BACK IN LIKE, I DON'T
KNOW, A WEEK, TEN DAYS, TO THEN
PLAY AT 100% EFFORT AND
INTENSITY IN THE PLAYOFF?
MAN, I LIKE YOUR SIXers, ERIN,
OVER THE NETS.
I DEFINITELY LIKE THE MILWAUKEE
BUCS OVER THE NETS.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> YOUR NETS TICKET.
>> YOU BOTH HAVE A GOOD POINT.
I STILL THINK THE NETS GET IT
DONE, EVEN WITH 85% JAMES
HARDEN.
YEAH, I NEED TO GIVE AWAY SOME
OF THESE HOODIES AND I ALSO GOT
TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT DGHER WHO SAYS MILWAUKEE
IN SEVEN, THE GREEK FREAK AIN'T
LOSING.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU DGHER.
ALTHOUGH YOU'RE FADING ME, I'M
STILL GIVING YOU A HOODIE.
I WILL GIVEAWAY ONE MORE HOODIE,
CABBIE.
MAMITO16 SAYS THE NETS ARE
UNDEFEATED AT HOME AGAINST THE
BUCS.
I BELIEVE THAT IS CORRECT.
I MEAN I BELIEVE THAT IS
CORRECT.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, MAMITO16.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CABBIE, ERIN, I'M GIVING AWAY A
JERSEY NOW.
I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE AWAY THIS
JERSEY.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT JULIO HERNANDEZ, SAYS,
GREG, THE BROOKLYN NETS ARE
GOING TO WIN THE SERIES IN SEVEN
GAMES.
UNTIL GIANNIS CAN PUT -- SO
SORRY.
HE WROTE A PARAGRAPH.
UNTIL GIANNIS CAN HIT PERIMETER
SHOTS AND FREE THROWS ON A
CONSISTENT BASIS, HE WILL COST
THE BUCS IN THE PLAYOFFS.
K.D. IS THE BEST PLAYER IN THE
SERIES.
NETS IN SEVEN.
HOT TAKE.
JULIO HERNANDEZ, SHOUT-OUT TO
YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY FOR YOUR HOT TAKE.
WE'LL SEE.
WE'LL SEE HOW THIS SERIES PLAYS
OUT.
CABBIE.
>> THAT IS A HOT TAKE.
WELL DONE.
LISTEN, JOHN HOLLINGER SAID THAT
AVAILABILITY IS ABILITY, AND IN
THIS YEAR'S PLAYOFFS IT FEELS
LIKE THE HEALTHIEST TEAM HAS THE
BEST CHANCE OF WINNING THE NBA
CHAMPIONSHIP.
THE SPORTS BOOKS ARE LEANING IN
THAT DIRECTION AS WELL, EXCEPT
FOR THE BROOKLYN NETS.
AGAIN, JAMES HARDEN'S HEALTH IS
QUESTIONABLE.
KYRIE IRVING'S HEALTH IS
BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
BROOKLYN NETS ARE STILL THE
BETTING FAVORITES TO WIN THIS
YEAR'S NBA CHAMPIONSHIP.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE LATEST
ODDS.
BROOKLYN IS RIGHT THERE WITH
PLUS 300.
THE MILWAUKEE BUCS AT PLUS 390.
PHOENIX IS UP, PLUS 390.
UTAH IS UP, PLUS 390.
AND THEN THE L.A. CLIPPERS AT
PLUS 550.
LET'S -- SORRY, THERE.
HAVING TROUBLE WITH MR. SUN CAME
OUT HERE.
SORRY, G-MONEY, IS THE AUDIENCE
STILL ON THE BROOKLYN NETS?
>> THE AUDIENCE, LET ME ASK
THEM, CABBIE.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHO YOU GUYS THINK IS WINNING IT
ALL.
CAN THE NETS DO IT WITH HARDEN
AND K.D.?
I THINK SO.
ERIN, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WHO ARE YOU ROCKING WITH?
>> GREG, I FEEL LIKE WE KEEP
ROCKING WITH THE NETS.
THOUGH AS YOU MENTIONED, CABBIE,
JUST THE HEALTHIEST TEAM IS
PROBABLY GOING TO WIN THE NBA
FINALS.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S WEAR AND
TEAR ON EVERY TEAM REMAINING.
AS A FAN I WANT THE 76ers TO WIN
IT ALL BUT I'M WORRIED ABOUT
EMBIID'S HEALTH, ESPECIALLY
AFTER LAST NIGHT'S LOSS.
THAT WHOLE SERIES BEING 2-2, IT
SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE.
THE NETS WIN IT ALL, PLUS 300,
IS MY PLAY GIVEN THAT.
IF THEY WIN TONIGHT OR THE NEXT
GAME, THOSE ODDS ARE COMING
DOWN.
IF YOU LIKE THE ODDS, GET THEM.
I THINK THE SUNS COME OUT OF THE
WEST, I'M ROOTING FOR THEM, BUT
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY WIN IT ALL.
SO I'M GOING WITH THE NETS.
>> ERIN, AT THIS POINT WITH
EMBIID'S TORN MENISCUS, DO YOU
THINK YOU CAN JUMP HIGHER THAN
HIM?
>> NO WAY.
NO WAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> ALL 5'2" OF ME JUMPING HIGHER
THAN EMBIID?
NO WAY.
>> LISTEN, HE DOESN'T HAVE THAT
MUCH LIFT.
G-MONEY AND I WERE AT THE GAME.
>> I KIND OF CRINGE WHEN I WATCH
HIM PLAY A LITTLE BIT RIGHT NOW,
TOO.
I'M SO WORRIED HE IS GOING TO BE
INJURED ON EVERY PLAY.
>> HE IS LABORING.
>> YEAH.
>> LISTEN, I HAVE PHILADELPHIA
76ers AND AN L.A. CLIPPERS
FUTURES TICKET.
I TRY NOT TO BE A PRISONER OF
THE MOMENT.
WHAT I SAW LAST NIGHT WITH
EMBIID GOING 0 FOR 12 IN THE
SECOND HALF, I WAS LIKE, UGH.
WHEN I SAW IN L.A. ON THE OTHER
SIDE, BOTH PAUL GEORGE AND KAWHI
LEONARD HAVING BACK-TO-BACK
30-POINT GAMES IS HISTORIC.
BUT THE ROAD TO THE NBA FINALS
GOES THROUGH SALT LAKE CITY, AND
THE UTAH JAZZ ARE AMAZING AT
HOME.
THEY HAVE THE NUMBER ONE SEED,
THEY'VE EARNED IT, AND THAT HOME
COURT ADVANTAGE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT.
DONOVAN MITCHELL, WE'RE NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT HIM, BUT HE'S BEEN
ELECTRIC.
HE IS AVERAGING 37 POINTS PER
GAME IN THIS SERIES AGAINST THE
CLIPPERS, AND -- BUT HERE IS THE
THING.
THIS ONE GIVES ME -- IT GIVES ME
A LITTLE BIT OF HOPE FOR MY L.A.
CLIPPERS' FUTURES TICKET.
IF MIKE CONNELLY DOESN'T PLAY IN
THE NEXT THREE GAMES, I THINK
L.A. CAN STEAL ONE IN SALT LAKE
CITY AND THEN WIN AT THE STAPLES
CENTER.
THEY CAN TAKE CARE OF THE
PHOENIX SUNS, WHO HAVE BEEN
RESTING FOR -- IT MIGHT END UP
BEING EIGHT OR NINE DAYS.
THAT REST CAN TURN INTO RUST,
AND MAYBE THEY CAN STEAL A GAME
IN PHOENIX.
I LIKE -- I'VE GOT A -- NOT
FLYers.
SIXers TICKETS THAT'S MY PICK TO
WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
GET THESE ODDS WHILE YOU CAN.
G-MONEY, DO YOU BELIEVE YOUR
GUY, DURANT, CAN CARRY THE
BROOKLYN NETS WITHOUT HIS
SUPERSTAR TEAMMATES AT FULL
HEALTH?
>> OH, CABBIE.
THAT IS A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
I'LL BE HONEST, AS GOOD AS I
THINK K.D. IS BY HIMSELF, I
DON'T THINK SO.
I DON'T THINK SO, CABBIE.
SO HE NEEDS, HE NEEDS JAMES OR
KYRIE TO BE ON THE TEAM IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO WIN THIS
CHAMPIONSHIP.
BUT I'M ROCKING WITH THE NETS.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE NETS.
I'VE BEEN ROCKING WITH THEM
SINCE THE BEGINNING, SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEASON.
I'M NOT GOING TO CHANGE MY BET
NOW.
GET 'EM AT PLUS 300 LIKE ERIN
SAID.
GET 'EM RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT IS
GOING TO CHANGE AFTER TONIGHT'S
GAME.
AFTER THE "W", I'M PREDICTING
IT, NOW YOU GUYS KNOW WHERE MY
BET IS ON THE GAME.
AFTER THE "W", THIS IS GOING TO
CHANGE.
LET ME GIVEAWAY SOME HOODIES.
LET ME GIVEAWAY SOME HOODIES,
CABBIE, KELLY -- NOT KELLY.
ERIN, SO SORRY.
>> THAT'S FINE.
>> IN THE COMMENTS, SUNS WILL
WIN IT ALL, GOOD NIGHT.
SHOUT-OUT TO DGHER.
SUNS WILL WIN IT ALL.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE, BUT WHY NOT?
WE'LL SEND YOU ANOTHER ONE.
I HAVE MOTIVATED CHRIS PAUL.
YOU GOT CHRIS PAUL IN THE SUNS,
IN THE COMMENTS.
THERE IT IS.
CHRIS PAUL WITH THE GIVE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU MOTIVATED.
CABBIE, ONE MORE, I HAVE ONE
MORE.
ONE MORE.
WADE 0821, YOU ARE GOING TO LIKE
THIS.
HE SAID, LET'S GO, PHILLY,
TAKING IT ALL THIS YEAR.
>> LOVE THAT.
>> SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, WADE 0821.
>> THOSE ARE GOOD VIBES.
>> WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
THERE IT IS.
THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN, CABBIE.
THEY'VE SPOKEN.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAPPING
IN "TO GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED BY
FanDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE AUDIENCE AND GREG AND ERIN
ARE ON THE BROOKLYN NETS TO WIN
THIS SERIES AND WIN THE NBA
CHAMPIONSHIP.
THE THREE-BY-TWO IS BACK, SO
LET'S GET IT TONIGHT.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT WEEK FOR --
TO GIVE AWAY MORE HOODIES, MORE
JERSEYS AND MORE LOCKS.
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN AND GREG
IVORY, MY NAME IS CABBIE
RICHARDS.
WE ARE LEAVING "THE GROUP CHAT."
♪ ♪
♪